The type of synchronization we use for atomic
sections is called mutual exclusion or lock. So this
is really an example of where a lock will
be needed. What we really need to do is
say something like, I'm entering, don't come in here.
Then do this, then say, I'm leaving, now you
can come in. And when this one is done,
this one can then say, I'm entering, I'm leaving.
But if this thread comes and wants to
continue past this point while the first thread is
already in the critical section, we should wait here.
So what we want here really is, before we
get into the critical section, qe need to lock,
a lock. Let's call that count lock that corresponds
to a given element of disarray. So count lock
of L is a lock that corresponds to count
of L. If this lock currently is open, then
we will enter. If this lock is currently locked,
then we will spin there until it becomes open.
Once we have grabbed the lock, we can enter here.
The other thread will do the same. So the
first one of them that succeeds in grabbing the lock
will enter this critical section. The other one will
now realize that this count lock has been locked and
will have to wait there. Once we leave
the critical section, we will unlock the lock. And
now, if this one is waiting here at that
point it sees that the lock is now available
and starts executing the critical section, and then releases
the lock. Note that having the lock and unlock
enforces mutual exclusion of this code. We do this
alone. And we do this alone. But it doesn't
impose a particular order between them. So, whichever
of them comes first to this lock will
execute its critical section first. So we can
either have this happen first, and then this happen
second. Or we can have this happens first,
and this happens second. What the lock is really
preventing is interleaving when these are happening simultaneously.
But it doesn't prevent, for example, this second thread
doing this first and only then the first thread gets to do it.